when I was more involved in yoga they
talked about Jesus too and they're like
yeah he's you know like there's ways to
see him right you know like he's a great
spiritual teacher he is the Son of God
he's one of them you know um there's
Krishna and Buddha along with him and
you're the Son of God right and I
actually went to school with a bunch of
Christians and they did not come out of
it Christian um like some of them still
say that they like pray to Jesus but
like they pray to him like as a spirit
guide along with these other gods I am
guarantee you these Christians did not
go here thinking that they were going to
give up their faith you know yeah I mean
if you believe in Christianity then it
wouldn't make sense to practice yoga if
there was nothing wrong with it I mean I
just don't say Christian pickle bable
why why you got to attach Christian in
front of it because you're trying to re
make sense of why you're doing this
thing that's like not compatible